What do we mean when we talk about animal abuse?
and animal exploitation?
Are they the same?
What are their differences?
Abuse would cause harm
physically or psychologically.
To exploit is to use someone by submission,
deception and without their free and informed consent.
That is why all animal use is always exploitation,
because there is always submission
and it's not like animals
can give us consent
or sign a contract in between.
If you realize
animals can be exploited without animal abuse.
This leads us to believe that
animal abuse is a problem,
the one in the background is the exploitation.
All mistreatment is exploitation,
but not all exploitation is mistreatment.
I understand.
Even
some animal operators
are in favor of welfare.
What is the opposite of abuse,
but are they not in favor of veganism?
What is the opposite of animal exploitation?